60 عاما من العلاقات الدبلوماسيه المتينه
انه تحالف القوى الكبرى يا ساده الدب
الروسي والمارد الجزائري راهن الجزائريون
على التحالف العسكري مع الروس تقدمت
الجزائر بخطوه اقتصاديه استفزازيه للاتحاد
الاوروبي باقترابها من تكتل بريركس الذي
تتزاعمه روسيا والصين صفقات ضخمه وتاريخيه
بين الجزائر وروسيا البلدان البعيدان
جغرافيا والقريبان عسكريا فما هي علاقه
بوتين بالجزائر وكيف تنظر لها الولايات
المتحده ولماذا تصر الجزائر على تسليح
جيشها بالسلاح الروسي عن علاقه بوتين
بالجزائر نتحدث وللقصه بقيه بوتين في
الجزائر في مطلع عام 2006 وصل الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين الى الجزائر ومن
هنا كانت البدايه لتجديد العلاقات بعد
فتره من الركود حيث سابقها اعلان عن الغاء
ديون جزائريه تعود الى عهد الاتحاد سابقا
ليلغي بوتين ديون الجزائريه قدرها اربعه
فاصله سبعه مليار دولار مقابل شراء
الجزائر لاسلحه وطائرات حربيه روسيه بقيمه
ثلاثه الفاصله خمسه مليار دولار فياال
ذكائك ايها الدب الروسي نسيت دين الماضي
لتكسب الحاضر والمستقبل هناك بدات اعاده
تسليح الجيش الجزائري من جديد وحصلت
الجزائر بموجب الصفقه على 40 طائره مايك
29 وعشرين طائره سوخوي و16 طائره ياك 130
المخصصه للتدريب وثمانيه انظمه صواريخ من
طراز اس 300 اضافه الى اربعين دبابه حديثه
وفق وكاله اوس شتات بريس حلفاء منذ عقود
بدات الحرب الاوكراني الغرب يجمعون
التحالفات بقياده واشنطن اوروبا تبحث عن
غاز البديل للغاز الروسي لسد مجاعه الطاقه
لديها فجاه يصل وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
سيرجي لاف الى الجزائر بزياره رسميه
والروس لا يزورون غير الدول الصديقه فقط
والرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين يتحدث
تفاعل روسيا مع الجمهوريه الجزائريه هو من
طبيعه الشراكه الاستراتيجيه وفي مارس من
عام 2022 احتفلنا بالذكرى الستيني للتاسيس
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه ودعونا الرئيس
الجزائري عبد المجيد تبون للقيامه بزياره
الى روسيا ليقف الحليف مع حليفه وترفض
الجزائر التصويت على قرار الامم المتحده
يطالب روسيا بالتوقف فورا عن استخدام
القوه ضد اوكرانيا تحرك الامريكان ومجموعه
من 27 عدوا منتخبا في الكونغرس تطالب وزير
الخارجيه الامريكي
بفرض عقوبات على بعض المسؤولين الجزائريين
الذين اتهموا بشراء اسلحه ضخمه من روسيا
فهي من بين اكبر ثلاث مشترين للاسلحه
الروسيه في العالم لكن بوتين لا يغامر
بادخال حليفه في مواجهه مع الغرب بقوله ان
روسيا تدعم الخط المتوازن الذي تنتجه
الجزائر في الشؤون الاقليميه والدوليه
الحياد الذي تلتزمه الجزائر في السياسه لن
يكون عسكريا ابدا فعندما يكون الامر
متعلقا بالسلاح العسكري يقع الاختيار على
سوق السلاح الروسي لان الروس لا يضعون
شروطا عند بيع الاسلحه والجزائر كما هو
معروف ذات حساسيه كبيره جدا حياله التدخل
في ط تقبل بذلك ابدا وهي تحافظ دائما على
استقلال قرارها السياسي والسبب الثاني ان
الضباط وكل عناصر الجيش الجزائري اعتادوا
على تكنولوجيا الاسلحه الروسيه وتالف معها
والاسلحه الروسيه مشهوره عالميا وذات قوه
وقدره قتاليه عاليه وهنا تكمن الرغبه
الجزائريه صفقات مرعبه قارب حجم التبادل
التجاري بين روسيا والجزائر ليكسر اربعه
مليارات دولار في العام 2021 لتوقع
الجزائر عقدا مع روسيا اسلحه روسيه جديده
وفقا لميله
سبعه مليارات دولار لكن الصفقه تمت دون
دعايه واسعه وفي جو من السريه اشترت
الجزائر بنشاط المعدات العسكريه
السوفياتيه ثم الروسيه وهي ثاني مستخدم
النشط للاسلحه الروسيه بعد الهند ويعتبر
الجيش الجزائري هو الاكثر استعدادا للقتال
في افريقيا فهو مسلح بانظمه روسيه متطوره
لكن جميع الاسلحه في كفه وانضمام مقاتلات
روسيه من الجيل الخامس سوء 57 في كفه اخرى
صفقه سيتم تسليمها في عام 2025 وفق
التقارير بعد اجراء المزيد من التعديلات
والتحسينات على الطائره وتبقى المفاجاه
القويه لاحتمال وصول نظام اس 500 المضاد
للطائرات الذي من شانه ان يكمل الدفاع
الجوي للبلاد بشكل مثالي والقصه لا تنتهي
هنا لتقوم روسيا بتزويد الجزائر بنظام اس
400 المضاد للطيران والذي يعتبر الاحسن في
العالم والقادر على مواجهه كل الطائرات
الغربيه مهما كانت قوتها بما في ذلك
الرافال الفرنسيه واف 35 الامريكيه وفي
عام 2014 موسكو تزود الجزائر سرا بصواريخ
اسكندر التي توصف بالمرعبه لانها ذات سرعه
فائقه وقوه تدميريه هائله بما فيها ضرب
السفن الحربيه في عرض البحر او ضرب اهداف
في الاراضي الاوروبيه الجنوبيه ولا يمكن
اعتراضها بسهوله بحسب مجله
وفي عام 2018 استلم الجيش الجزائري انظمه
قاذفه اللهب الثقيله
الملقبه بالشمس الحارقه ومع اواخر خريف
عام 2018 تحركت الى الجزائر احدى اخطر
الغواصات بالعالم غواصه الثقب الاسود التي
تنثر الرعب باعماق البحار وحصلت الجزائر
على اثنتين من هذه الغواصه اطلق عليهما
اسماء الاوراس صفر 31 والهقار 032 ليتجاوز
المبلغ الاجمالي للعقود خلال هذه السنوات
13.5 مليار دولار لينتهي عام 2022 بصفقه
بيع اسلحه بين البلدين بقيمه 12 حتى 17
مليار دولار وفق صحيفه الشرق الاوسط
الاسلحه الروسيه جعلت الجيش الجزائري
الاقوى في شمال افريقيا
تمكن الجزائر بهدوء من انشاء اقوى جيش في
المنطقه خلال عشرين عاما فقط بترسانته
التكنولوجيه الروسيه بشكل اساسي تكتل
اجتماع الكبار بعد ان راهنت على التحالف
العسكري مع روسيا تقدم الجزائر على خطوه
اقتصاديه مهمه وهي استفزازيه للاتحاد
الاوروبي في الوقت ذاته انها الانضمام الى
التكتل الاقتصادي البيريكس الذي تتزعمه
روسيا والصين تستغل الجزائر لذلك دعم
روسيا في طلب الانضمام لمجموعه بيريكس وهو
طموح تسعى لبلوغه في اقرب وقت ممكن وهنا
يصرح الروس قائلين ان موسكو لا تعترض على
رغبه الجزائر في الانضمام الى المجموعه
وماذا بعد ايها الجزائريون بينما يتصيد
الامريكان الاخطاء للجزائر تفتح روسيا
مخازن اسلحتها المرعبه بدون قيد او شرط
للجزائريين قائلين لهم فلتختار ما شئتم يا
هؤلاء فالحليف لا يترك حليفه ليصل صدى هذا
التحالف الى الولايات المتحده فهل حان وقت
تقديم واشنطن بعد التنازلات للجزائر ام ان
الرئيس تبون وحكومته مكتفون بالتحالف مع
الدب الروسي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]